now megan mccain who recently departed
as a co-host of abc's the view speaking
out ready to tell her story to speak
candidly and reveal what went on behind
the scenes and explaining why she left
and previewing what's ahead she is now
releasing a new audiobook memoir and
it's called bad republican you might
remember these moments from the view
where her co-host frankly i can't put it
any other way which is downright cruel
and mean take a look
the idea that there isn't fighting
within the democratic party as well
i know i was talking right i'm talking
about i'm talking about somebody
absolutely you treated me so much when i
was on maternity leave you missed me so
much you missed fighting with me
i did not miss you
okay
somebody let somebody answer the
question
moving on i i like to weigh in
okay guys guys
hold on hold on stop everybody stop
everybody stop that's so rude
my job here is not to litigate the
ethics of it i'm an abc political
analyst along with being a view co-host
my job is to analyze the politics of it
and i'm telling you but i'm talking
about you i'm talking about i'm
please stop talking please stop talking
right now because you know what's
happening thank you thank you i won't
talk the rest of the show okay that's
i'm okay with that
i'm okay with that if you're gonna
behave like this i'm not behaving like
you are
yourself perspective yes we are talking
we're not doing anything how about this
former fbi we'll be right back
here to explain author of the new audio
memoir bad republican megan mccain
i'm just traumatized looking at it uh
man that's brutal
um tell us about it
i mean those are two of the moments in
my new audible memoir that i speak about
the last moment was actually my second
day back from maternity leave and
i had very severe postpartum anxiety and
that moment triggered a panic attack
backstage i vomited in
my office
it was horrible i started crying between
commercial breaks and it was the moment
that i just thought that my four years
uh in an anthropological experiment in
left-wing media had come to an end
because
i really enjoyed my four years of the
view in the sense that i found it a
great challenge it's a huge platform
people watch it it's the number one show
in daytime but
you are targeted if you're the token
conservative and you are treated
differently and it's been interesting
having my
book excerpt released today because
people just really don't seem to be
surprised at all but there is validation
in hearing it from my mouth and i felt
like it was really time for me to show
my story instead of having it through
the lens of the liberal media and the
liberal people who were leaking from
internally on the show i worked on and i
felt like it was important for mothers
to hear that it's okay you don't have to
put yourself or your pregnancies in a
position where you could possibly have
your health or your mental health put in
a position of toxicity and i decided to
leave after i became a mother and that
was ultimately the game changing moment
for me
megan you even went as far as to say you
felt like you'd been slapped and you you
called the work environment you know
toxic direct and purposeful
hostility and none of that looked fun to
me and and i could say in complete
honesty i've had minor little skirmishes
here and there with with a few on-air
talent
but nothing like this at all ever not
even close i mean this is like a
cancerous environment
yeah and it's all very personal that's
the thing is that being a conservative
woman in mainstream media is deeply
threatening being a woman who can hold
her own on a show like that proved to be
ultimately threatening so it became more
and more personal the stronger the show
got that was the ironic part of it is
the better the show did after we won an
emmy we were on the cover of the new
york times magazine as the most
important political show in america i
felt like the toxicity got worse and
worse i actually felt like the more
successful i was on the view and the
more moments i helped get them and the
more i pressed liberal candidates and
liberal guests on the show the worse it
got for me backstage and then ultimately
it started spilling out on air um look i
worked at fox news before i went to the
view and
i probably would not have survived
emotionally the past you know five years
of my life between my dad's passing and
cancer and everything that i speak about
in my memoir happening at the view and
other things in my personal life if it
weren't for the women that i met at fox
news janis dean kennedy dagin kat timf
there's actually an entire chapter about
cat timf and how she helped me through
grief i had a sisterhood at fox that i
lost at the view and i know what women
supporting women looks like because i
had it when i worked at fox news and now
i know what the entire opposite
experience is and
it honestly it's been difficult to open
up to people like you sean but i felt
like it was important to say that there
is real trauma
that is involved when you are targeted
and targeted and targeted for not voting
for president obama for being a pro-life
woman and i don't think that people who
go into liberal spaces which is
basically every other space except fox
news and media i don't think you should
be punished for it and i don't think
your personal life should be impacted
and that's unfortunately exactly what
happened to me
why did you you tell the story that your
dad encouraged you to take the job why
he loved the show he you know it's a
mainstream show and i do think it's
important that we have to fight the
culture war in their spaces because
quite frankly i think we're losing it
and he thought that they needed a strong
conservative there had been a whole host
of uh republican and so-called
republican women women who claimed to be
republican but are not in my opinion who
had co-hosted the show and failed and he
thought i was up for the job and i did
anything he told me to do so i did it
and i actually really enjoyed
the first year and a half of the show
but like i said as i grew stronger and
more and more uh people would come on
the show when i would really hold
liberal guests feet to the fire i i felt
a lot of backlash both internally and
externally at the show but it shouldn't
become as a surprise to you i mean
you've you you know you've seen the show
i think anyone who has watched even a
clip of this and i used to not be
surprised by anything i'm saying i i
remember the last time i did the sh i
did the last time i did the show sitting
next to rosie o'donnell and it became a
screaming match and barbara walters
couldn't stop it and it just uh we'll go
to break now and i was like why am i
wasting my time you know in the middle
of this because i don't go to bed till 4
a.m anyway
um
there were a lot of
a lot of issues and and i did support
your data as you know in 2008 and i also
had political disagreements with your
dad very strong ones uh especially on
the health care vote i was pretty
unhappy with it
um
your dad was a guy that was willing to
have a lot of conflicts with people and
that happened after his funeral too
when
campaign managers and even governor
palin apparently in this leaked list
weren't invited to the funeral why did
that all happen
yeah i actually have a chapter about
this in my book where i have a whole new
lens of viewing how sarah palin was
treated and how the people working for
my father's campaign uh really you know
in my opinion treated her really
horribly set her up for failure i think
when you're seeing katie couric talking
about how ruth bader ginsburg is someone
she helped look good i thought well
obviously with her book and i thought
that obviously she probably put sarah
palin in a position to look bad and by
the way nicole wallace was the person
who facilitated that interview who now
has a show on msnbc and i just as i've
gotten older like i fell in love with a
really
deeply conservative man who runs the
federalist i have gotten older it's like
the old adage if you're not liberal when
you're young you don't have a heart if
you're not conservative and you're old
you don't have a brain and yeah i just
really hope that the culture has some
redemption for sarah palin in the same
way that we have for so many other women
right now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else